l attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigenti prima di
cominciare con il video ragazzi volevo
ricordarvi che domenica c'è l'ultima
data di made in internet che sarà torino
quindi nel caso ci vediamo io lascio le
info di mente indescrizioni siamo
ritornati sua way out
il primo episodio è andato benissimo e
vi ringrazio un sacco eccovi con il
secondo che tra l'altro ha uno sviluppo
molto inaspettato buona visione
ma che belle ma dovremo rimasti il mio
aspetto ritirata perché tu hai citato la
roba sono stefano e modelli di salirci
sei un genio per visitarla per terra non
sono un po stupido venire lasciata lì ma
porca vacca rilanciarla da un'altra
parte
adesso siamo diventati siamo passati in
assassin's creed dobbiamo arrampicarci
del prendere gol a robinho che non
avevano dei dunque tu riesci a ottenere
qualsiasi cosa in sé la prigione vuoi
fare una roba la fai finiti ok facciamo
finta di usare il moccio e poi ci penso
io posso rompere questo cosa aspetta la
roma che aveva ben capito cosa mi sembra
questa cosa ma non ci sono più le scopi
di una volta dunque è la mia scopa si è
spezzata infilate la nel deretano resta
qui va bene a se n'è andato adesso posso
provare il salina spesso se togliamo se
riesco e non so se non smentisce casto
facendolo salire la forza saluto ad
ottenere io a vieni vieni corri
ok ma salta su stata su c.so ci lasciamo
ora è lodevole solito sul catrame è una
merda ai castelli o il cavalcavia di
mario
a chiamare che voleva con me vediamo i
nomi che vede niente pletamente secolo
qua lo scalpello vaiano come scendi
guardami seri realtà la scampa ad oslo
torrenti altro faccio stand di quelle da
non sapere ora c'è un passaggio sul
personaggio dove c'è un passaggio è
passati sopra passati sopra aspetto è
questo qua è la scena si chiede di come
file avere quella barba merli ok poi c'è
adesso divisa ecco esatto lucernario
bravo mi chiamo una roba lì non è non è
uno scalpello
non è chiaro si imprigiona che esce da
lì quando ha riferito che do scappano
entrare porta lo scopo di riuscire ecco
bravo no questo è chiusa tono bloccata
senza saperla quater apro io il calore
va aiutarlo io qui grazie prego prego
grazie al quale salta il freddo da
livello alto glielo devi dare ok
perfetto non siamo stati bravissimi dice
sì sì molto facile quando quest anno
passato l'infanzia raccogliere scalpelli
io non ho idea tanto la sera seguente
poverino ciao a freddo mi dai un bello
scalpello vincerà il libro su di
scarselli per soffrire così specie da
leggere ai propri laghi quello di
violachannel pincha ragazza fatta
nascondono scalpore nell'atto 10 in
pelle la mia libero lo scapolo 20 ace
lorenzo è lo scalpello maschile viso
cavare azione nella cella scappa dalla
cella ma come ma come è possibile è
scappata da quell'ultimo livello
no no no no allora fermi ma io cosa fai
un attimo
devo dire anche a farmi capire se ci
beccano si aspetta che non la guardia
che anzi river e distrae distrae che
chiamava proprio adesso posso avere
altre lenzuola ci ho pagato dentro quel
che faccio adesso
perché se non hai c arresterà rono si
sia fai da solo perché sia ovvio non
sono attendibili ha riscosso vedere
d'acqua ok io qua sono bella cui quasi
paiono posteri michael jackson parliamo
6 michael j
vai aspettava imparava rampa vai vai vai
staccherò mai celato c'è l'altro un
posto
porca vacca meno male che non ascolti me
perché sentiva vicino a puntare la
torcia in faccia tutto il giorno appena
questo se ne va a proto guardare lei
guardi il mondo vostro favore il
rapimento subito vai veloce
spero perché se non è dietro un casino
[Risate]
livello distraggo più di come la basta
uno scalpello brucia di prigione di far
da qualche macello come si fa a sismi
veloce zio però toro perfetto metti
metti metti metti metti la metti metti
il fai nulla nulla nulla nulla paolo per
nulla
no no no a chiamata per checco
bellissimo benissimo
sei stato bravissimo a 776 ferma mai
vai vai tranquillo non c'è nessuno vai
vai tu vai come se non ci fosse un
domani scuola come se fosse la madre del
tuo peggior nemico scava così miccia sì
sì sì la mamma di avevo già nel 1600
eccola qui conosci da mare l'amaro che
vede la palestra
ok perfetto
mettici successo bravissimo così il mio
braccio destro è il male perché come
saresti scavato d'accordo che cantelmo
adesso di passarla me devo farlo io bye
bye bye set
ora controllano la chimica devo fare sta
roba controlla controllano tra fuori con
traforato che 102
ok basta mettere questo qua sta
avvenendo nati mista pisciando l'altro
sta tornando
se se se se io vado a dormire il cielo
prevenuto ok se tu vuoi dirmi che questi
che vai farai perfetto controllo dai tu
così la donna che bello però altra parte
dall'altra parte un altro tranquillo
tranquillo distrae la cosa
ok a posto ho fatto l'ho fatto io gli
strati 600 volte e pensiamo già
scappando e bello come ma adesso
scappando di prigione
adesso il secondo episodio più sono alti
palco info da una bara questo c'era
qualcosa sicuro per tre anni fa ci siamo
se ti giuro su sto dando il ci posso
credere non ci sono ma anche 3 2 1 gol
da cosa posso fare le monde non ci
becchino arrivati che a quel punto le
comunque mano passa attraverso sistemi
non sta entrando aveva detto hanno
spento le luci minori controllano fino
al giorno dopo
metti il csa posto
dovevamo mettere un di cuscini nei denti
sotto le coperte e facce e ti stanno
usando il deretano fossi un buon
cagnolino che poi verrà la gara è
bellissima mangi dormi a fare un po come
youtube e allora visto che io non ero
pronto a fare la fuga adesso ok usata o
guarda ho trovato una pira pavan il
quale ho ma tieni eccoci qua
fare scappiamo ci porti come ricordo
questo è perfetto per fermare a vento
l'acqua
passiamo tratta solamente di c2 con dio
dio ci piace ma ti avrei fatto tranciati
perchè so che in dialetto no devi
spegnere la ventola lì ci sia un modo
per spegnere posso devastato stata
un'emozione squadra allora ecco bar a
cedere il coso spegnerà in qualche modo
fa posto perfetto ma ci sei perfetto
arrivo
mamma mia ha posto la regia sei stato
bravo come elettricista ora dobbiamo
passare di qua e là dove portano ste
porte qua questo ciò ecco perche era
meglio non scoprire un'amicizia ma è un
casino bene l'uomo dava ma dove porta
sta roba aspettare da un ideale sic
cosa sta facendo certi sarà ritrovare
applix per forza questo mica l'artigiano
fallire ok win it and find you ain't del
suo consueto a ok vedi col signor sensi
siena
[Musica]
di non la manda nella mischia si pensa
ma poi con i ricordi non siano dei buoni
pasto hayden aspetti
poi il leader nel rispetto dopo e
barrete non ottimali sony sulle cose che
i sensitivi subito ok
ma ci salviamo qualora ci sta dai
bambini rare coperti di lega leggo mi
sembrava strano che volessero fuggire
adesso infatti se non solo capendo
sarebbero fermati hanno fatto una
transizione
ciao io c'era questo disco è scusato
lasciati lì davanti leggo questa lega
tutti scegliere magazzino ho capito ma
allora abbiamo bisogno del carrello che
questo lo mettiamo come suoneria via
next week end e il coach mi servirebbe
un libro carrellino chiesto a lui di
fare tanto male perfetto non corretto
easy o corrotto easy con delle sigarette
io questo c'erano la cella mi sto
dedicando con pazzo e sono entrato nell
aspetto fisico aiuto sono entrato qui
dentro ci siamo pieni di arrivo arrivo
luci hicks devi riempire sta roba di
lenzuola e mi ci ficco dentro ma che
coach o nel suolo aspetta penso o la
loro possono avere invece di buttarli
stiamo mettendo le lenzuola per fare la
corda ma non so quanti ok perfetto
perfetto vieni qua ma che ci stiamo
imboccando per fare le cose bruttissime
vai come tu stai bene vai tu stai lì che
figata di tipo
[Applauso]
omar agli integratori passare di qua io
se mi fa passare a lo controlla lui
ok se vuoi avere qualche ma anche
controllato meglio vediamo cosa c'è qui
ok chiuso
va bene che gli utenti ecco io devo fare
ti portano dentro qualche parte di strà
questa funzione può riuscire ad esso è
uscito da sono uscito e di sbloccare
questa porta qui la devi sbloccare
capito o calcio si aspetta la vendita
metti un po diventato vedo se riesco a
provocare la gente insomma fuori 17 st
capelli un modo perfetto il papa allora
paielli di ad altro verso le sei proprio
tu per come tutti pensano a staffetta
tra l'altro delle guardie che sono
bravissime intervenire bravi complimenti
a prima aprirà mai aperta e gravissimo
perché solo quando se non mi guarda
rispetto all'altra parte
attento ok adesso vieni qua se facciamo
salire a ok perfetto pesco
sa cosa mi sto attaccando non sono cosi
ma senza la passione subito niente
facciamo siamo così che grazie amico io
ad essere spesso la musica dei quattro
c'è la musica adeguate e non lo so ci
sarà un modo per passare dai dolci
grazie passo suo gioco siamo bravissimi
da me le altre mentre vai veloce che ha
posto ci siamo 323 bisogna darne anche
di più tre è il numero perfetto
ma torniamo ci sta ci sparano in faccia
presto perché camminavo roma niente
fatta sono stati bravissimi a son
tornati lì proprio ok hanno fatto la
corda perché chi scende dal primo io non
avevo quindi ragazzuoli ce la stiamo
facendo però interrotto qua perché per
sono un po una testa di kakà cosa il
ragazzino cresciuto molto mi piace che
le risorse con i giustizialisti atene ci
vediamo
[Musica]